je pense que les jambes à mon profit
c'est important qu'à un moment donné on
puisse prendre conscience que on a notre
mot à dire
justement pour que la jeunesse puisse
comprendre que c'est une voie sans issue
ce fait est orienté vers l'action facile
tout ça ça va un temps mais sur un long
terme on est perdant mais ça c'est un
truc
il faut se servir des gens comme nous en
fait qu'ils ont raté leur genèse qui ont
raté leur leur passé pour éviter que des
gens plus jeunes puisque l on n a pas
trop fait donc en fait c est en train
d'avoir lieu c'est possible donc c'est
encore difficile justement vous donner
la parole aux prévenus
je pense que plus on donnera la parole
aux gens qui sortent de prison et qui
sont prêts à s'exprimer plus on ira dans
ce sens et plus je pense que il va avoir
de la migration ce sujet mais plus on va
continuer d'enterrer d'étouffer ce qui
sort de prison à les considérer comme
foutu fichu et - déjà on aura de chances
de pouvoir se racheter
moi je pars du principe que si
aujourd'hui j'arrive à dissuader des
jeunes j'arrive à vraiment intervenir
dans leur vie en faisant en sorte qu'ils
puissent faire les bons choix
je pense que ça contribuera aussi au
fait que j'essaie d'avoir inséré
j'essaie de me racheter aussi dans la
société